so when I say who do you want me to
interview one of the most common names
that comes up is ben shapiro as i've
said before i'm glad to talk to Ben
Shapiro on the program anytime I would
gladly appear on Ben's new Sunday
special program anytime although I don't
think he's interested in appearing on my
show and I don't think he's particularly
interested in having me on his show but
what we do have and this is an interview
that a lot of people have not seen
because the channel was like one-fifth
its current size when the center of you
went down many years ago is that I
actually did interview ben shapiro some
years ago and we talked about gun
control primarily there are some
interesting moments there are some funny
moments but in the absence of a new
interview with ben or my appearance on
his program this is the last time that
Ben and I spoke in a public broadcast
setting
joining me is Ben Shapiro he's Breitbart
news editor at large also author of the
new book bullies how the left's culture
of fear and intimidation silences
America so Ben I saw your recent
appearance with Piers Morgan it was very
very entertaining I think you did way
better than Alex Jones did I'm hoping
though that we can have really kind of a
productive conversation I mean we have
what we're the same age we have similar
backgrounds both have families with ties
to the Holocaust and and Eastern Europe
and politically we are very very
different but that being said I would
love to see if we can get any kind of
consensus on assuming that we're both
kind of in good faith really have the
goal of reducing the number of people
killed by guns in the u.s. which I
believe that you do and I know speaking
for myself that I do can we come to some
kind of consensus about really what
would help putting aside whether those
solutions would fall under democratic or
republican ideas so a good place a good
place to start I think Ben is what do
you think really is the cause of gun
violence in this country I mean is it is
it education is it the wrong people
having guns is it too many guns is it
not enough guns as some people has said
is it liberals I mean what is the
problem no I mean I think the problem is
is culture what
see is a vast variety of differences gum
laws and gun effects I mean New
Hampshire has virtually no gun laws it
has the lowest gun violence crime rate
in the nation
Chicago obviously has tremendously heavy
gun laws and has one of the highest gun
violence rates in the nation more people
were killed in Chicago by handguns last
year than were killed in Afghanistan
among coalition troops last year so yeah
I think that the bottom line is this it
comes down to culture and how do we
inculcate a culture that that that
really you know takes violence seriously
and and takes gun ownership seriously
and you know that that may mean tailored
solutions for four different for
different cultural backgrounds but it's
the then that seems to me the the real
root of the problem otherwise we can
pass as many gun laws as we want but the
truth is this you know Britain has a lot
of gun laws on the books they have five
times our violent crime rate so if we
really want to end not just gun violence
but violence violence then that's going
to take a shift in culture more
generally yeah and you know part of what
you're saying I completely agree with I
mean if we look at Switzerland I think
Switzerland is a good example where we
actually have government provided guns
with a lot of training for people who
live in Switzerland the guns are then
kept in people's homes there's tons of
guns in Switzerland but you don't
actually have a much gun crime at all so
I think the problem is I'm not actually
against whether I'm for or against guns
in the abstract I think is less relevant
for whatever reason Americans are
committing violence with guns and that's
really I think the problem we have to
focus on right Americans I mean I think
that we have to distinguish between
groups it's easy to say you know all of
America has a gun violence problem but
it's also not true right New Hampshire
and Vermont do not have a gun violence
problem Chicago does have a gun violence
problem in Washington DC has a gun
violence problem big big cities that are
heavily populated across the United
States seem to have much more of a gun
problem than more rural areas even if
the gun ownership rate is higher in the
rural areas so we have to be looking at
solutions that will actually work and
the truth is that broadly tailored
salute mean it's possible there's a
different solution for Chicago than
there is for for Montana but I think
that we have to be as careful and
meticulous in crafting solutions as we
can so my concern when you said that
before was
we may need to craft solutions that are
tailored for each culture it starts to
border that could be interpreted as
saying it needs to be determined by race
potentially I mean along what lines
explain more because I don't want you to
be accused of that if that's not what
you mean yeah no this has nothing to do
with race this has to do with profile
really young men between the ages of all
races between the ages about 16 and 25
you know you know that most of the gun
violence in this country is committed by
young men aged 16 to 25 men who come
from predominantly single mother
backgrounds who have poor levels of
education who grew up in poverty those
would be those would be good weighing
factors and what we have to do is we
have to create a culture with strong
male role models a culture where people
have the opportunity to get out of
poverty and a culture honestly we needed
we need to jail more criminals I mean
one of the one of the biggest problems
that we see is that if you keep
criminals off the streets they can't be
out committing crimes we see recidivism
and and you know criminals committing
multiple crime said okay let's stop
there for a second because I'm glad
you're getting through the jail thing
because I think this is a big factor
specifically what types of criminals do
you want to jail because I actually
think that a lot of the problem maybe
you're talking about different criminals
than I'm thinking of but I think the
drug war is a big factor here I think
the fact that we have this
criminalization of even marijuana in
many cases which is creating dangerous
situations if we had marijuana for
example which I'm I don't I don't smoke
weed I'm not this is not a personal
thing for me but it's I think that if we
eliminated the the entire culture that's
surrounded by marijuana being something
that's illegal we would eliminate a ton
of gun crime you know I think there may
be truth to that I'm actually very torn
on the marijuana legislation because I
don't think that it's been effective and
I don't think that it's effectively
enforced I do tend to think that the
folks who are committing criminal acts
will find a will find another market
shall we say with with illegal
substances that will you know that will
allow them to engage their best their
their most marketable attributes which
in this case seems to be violence and
and illegal activity and that may apply
your son but the vast majority of people
who at least are purchase
marijuana's maybe that applies to some
of the dealers but you know a lot of
these gunfights that start from people
buying drugs that'll go away I think
well most of the guns I mean a lot of
those gunfights that are starting from
buying drugs those are by people who are
in the trade I mean when you're talking
about the normal marijuana user which is
really what you're talking about here
you know drug dealers are not folks who
we need to find a way to let off the
hook I think that drug users may be I
know that's a that's a whole different
discussion but essentially we're talking
about the government sanctioning and
regulating those drug dealers right I
mean the question is what happens to the
drug dealers right right right I don't
think they're gonna become pharmacists
so they go back to the thing which is
which criminal which criminals do you
want to put in jail because I think jail
population being completely blown up is
part of the problem here Oh see I
disagree I think the easiest way to keep
criminals from committing crimes do not
have them in the general population so
anybody who's convicted of a violent
crime should be spending longer in
prison not last time I mean in the state
of California yeah there was this crazy
case that happened a few weeks back
where a guy was let out of prison based
on an old rape law uncovered video his
original sentence for rape was three
years I mean that's insanity is serving
three years for a rape is craziness so I
agree with that okay
crime needs to be we need more police
forces we need heavier police forces and
we need and we need more police presence
in downtrodden areas in order to in
order to really have you know a presence
in crime heavy neighborhoods all of that
needs to happen as far as but but what I
like about this David and I appreciate
it is that we're having a discussion
about the crime areas right we're not
having a discussion about what has to
happen to 300 million Americans in order
to make sure that we don't have Sandy
Hook we're having a discussion on how do
we target the folks who are responsible
for things like Sandy Hook or like the
gun violence in Chicago and those area
and I agree with you on having this
conversation but I think if we are
talking about gun violence we can't
ignore the specifics of guns so I would
love to get you to comment on that a
little bit I mean I think we agree on
one thing which is assault weapons bans
are not the solution particularly simply
because of the fact that it's mostly
handguns when we talk about the
homicides over a year that are leading
to death now you asked Piers Morgan why
don't you just say you want to ban all
handguns and he
reticent to do that and whatever reasons
he had I don't know but asking you
should anything happen with guns should
there be more guns less guns what do we
do about the gun specifically you know
more guns in the hands of people who are
responsible when West guns in the hands
of people who are irresponsible so
that's why I said on the show I'm in
favor of background checks I have no
problem with background checks and I you
know generally speaking I don't have a
problem with the idea that you have to
be trained to own a gun so that you
actually know what you're doing with it
I don't I don't like these are all
things that I don't see as significantly
burdensome to to obtaining a gun now I
understand the argument of people like
drama with him and Friends that creating
more barriers means that it's a longer
time between when you can apply for a
gun and when you when you can get it and
in many cases you don't have that much
time here's the thing let me stop there
though if you're really in a situation
we're having to wait a week or two to
get a gun is specifically putting your
life in danger you should really be in
touch with law enforcement I don't think
that that's a legitimate good thing you
know I think let's put it this way I
think that there are exceptions to that
rule but I think generally that's
correct I don't think law enforcement
can can do everything though so I'm I'm
more sympathetic to it than you are but
I understand your argument and I and I
sort of agree with it okay so then let's
get to the other aspect which is I think
where you started to lose some people
when you were talking to Piers Morgan is
when we go into this issue of to defend
ourselves from from the government which
may become tyrannical I understand that
in a theoretical world this is possible
but I think you lose a lot of people
with when you go into that argument that
doesn't appeal to as many people as I
respect the Second Amendment well I
agree that but the problem is this and
this is this is really the fundamental
issue and this is why I went there with
Pearce I think it is very very very
important that when we say that we
support the Second Amendment we
understand why we support it and people
on the left any of them and it doesn't
have to be a left-right issue but the
folks sort of pro-gun control they they
say they support the Second Amendment
then they can't explain why they don't
want a blanket gun ban and you saw that
with peers that he wouldn't come out in
favor of a blanket handgun ban no every
justification that he had used for you
know banning for example ar-15 is doubly
true with regard to handguns but he
wasn't talking about that and so you
know what all I want from the left is
Kohi like i know why i defend the Second
Amendment I really do like I do defend
it on the basis that the founders
defended it which is that an armed
population is the best guarantee against
against tyranny but you know if you
don't agree with that then I think that
it's it's important for people it let's
say you're a Second Amendment if a
Second Amendment
make you late the rationale behind why
I'm the Second Amendment why is it good
for people to own guns because for
appears later in that same show after I
left he admitted it that if he had his
druthers he would get rid of all guns on
American soil yeah the only thing is
that Justice Antonin Scalia has said a
lot of the same things that Piers Morgan
has has said I think that we get into a
we get a little muddled when we talk
about exactly what the founders intended
because let's be honest everything was
very different when the founders wrote
that second amendment so I don't know
that just saying we have I don't I don't
like to focus on the commas in the
Second Amendment this is so to speak I
don't think that's true though I think
that the Second Amendment is largely
about human nature and the fact is that
we have seen tyranny on American soil I
mean we had we had 120,000 Japanese
folks who were in prison during World
War two we had Jim Crow and South for a
hundred years
we had slavery in this country for 480
years after the after the Declaration of
Independence so you know I think that
it's it's a mistake to imagine the
democracy the the best guarantee I mean
if you read the Second Amendment it's
not about the commas the Second
Amendment is very clear on why it's
there right I mean it says a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the preservation of a free State I
mean that's that is the point the Free
State is the point is that you and
welcome Alysha meant every person aged
16 to 45 I mean that's in u.s. code
we're going to draw the line on what
specifically in terms of arms and
weapons are are allowed in other words
my interpretation and this may be this
may be not nuanced enough I say if it
was if we are there kind of two options
in my mind either it applies to the
weapons that were available when the
Second Amendment was written or there
are absolutely no restrictions and this
goes to shoulder mounted RPGs and
everything and let me just finish my
thought here if we are able to draw a
line somewhere the lines that the NRA
wants to draw are no
more or less legitimate than the lines
President Obama or Dianne Feinstein may
want to draw and the reason I disagree
with that is because I think that you
can draw lines based on the principle
now the Second Amendment was not written
for muskets it was and and proof is in
the pudding if they say if we if we're
going to be that literal about the about
the Second Amendment and and the Second
Amendment says arms it doesn't say
muskets if we if we're going to assume
that it just meant stuff that happened
at the time then Piers Morgan has no
right to be on TV because there were no
TVs and in 1789 and the freedom of the
press doesn't use a printing press so I
mean as long as we're gonna go there we
may as well go all the way and then
where do we limit to RPGs or nuclear
arms those are arms right they're not
but actually the the if you look at the
Second Amendment the Second Amendment
doesn't guarantee your right to own a
warship right it doesn't guarantee the
right to own a cannon even even but hold
on a second one of the main tenets of
those who are constitutionalist is that
the Constitution only says what you
can't do and the Second Amendment
doesn't say you can't own a warship nope
correct Second Amendment that is true
the Second Amendment does negative that
right so in other words it's not
actually you're wrong on that it
prevents the government from infringing
in areas where it says that you can't
infringe so the so that is actually the
this is this was the argument about the
Bill of Rights at the time actually the
Bill of Rights are kind of different
from the rest of the Constitution and
that they carve out areas that the
government cannot go that's why there
was argument about the Bill of Rights
the Constitution is a document of
negative liberties the Bill of Rights is
is also a document of negative liberties
but it carves out actual spaces where
government can't go that's why I mean
you know this this is why there was the
debate between the Federalists and the
anti-federalists anti-federalists said
there's no point to a Bill of Rights it
actually infringes our Liberty because
it says to the government that it can go
all these other areas the Second
Amendment said when it says that you did
the right to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed it also it doesn't sit
first of all the Second Amendment
applies to the federal government not to
the states but and that is a huge thing
that has been overlooked in
constitutional history but even assuming
that it applies to the states the fact
is the state has always had and always
did have the ability to prevent private
citizens from owning cannon I mean there
were there were laws on the books when
the Constitution was written
preventing people from owning certain
types of weapons the argument you're
making now is actually that the Second
Amendment does not prevent anybody from
owning warships but it's the state
superseding that Bill of Rights that
that would allow them to prevent someone
from owning a warship it's getting a
little muddled right it's not though I
mean that's that's correct the Second
Amendment doesn't prevent you from doing
anything I mean the First Amendment
doesn't prevent you from doing anything
okay with the state's drawing the lines
on what guns you can have but not the
federal government it's a restriction on
government right I mean the Second
Amendment is not created as a
restriction on individual it's not a law
about what guns you can and cannot own
it's restriction on what the state can
do and what it says that the state can
do is it says the state is not allowed
to infringe your right to bear arms now
the question becomes what is the
definition of arm rights oh yeah yeah
yeah I think most likely this is
interesting because we could probably go
on 20 more minutes and we probably
wouldn't come to an agreement on this
but I think this is really we were doing
fine agreeing on a lot of stuff until we
got to this and I think this is where a
lot of people are getting lost also I
think it's a very simple argument from
my point of view and that is the people
if they have the right to bear arms in
order to prevent tyranny then that that
goes for arms to prevents it that goes
to the the ultimate limit of that is the
arms necessary to prevent the basically
you can own any arm that is necessary to
necessary not rather than to prevent
tyranny well this isn't because in Waco
Texas the Wynn Waco Texas in Waco Texas
the government use tanks isn't it then
reasonable to say people need tanks
because they were used in Waco Texas
this is the balance that we draw right
and this is true for all legit
subjective though been totally
subjective the fact is that if you if
you disarm a population of rifles there
is no chance that it could be a popular
resistance to terror a period and if you
only give them rifles and the tanks roll
out the rifles are useless is it's just
not true I mean I've spoken to two
veterans at the War College who who have
done studies of what would happen in
case of an armed insurrection in the
United States if the American population
is armed with semi-automatic rifles the
army cannot handle them now god forbid
it should ever come to that point
obviously and I don't think at that
point now but but the argument that you
need tanks in order to resist tyranny is
true and obviously the the menace to
Public Safety provided by tanks is
significantly higher than the Menace
provided by a semi-automatic rifle which
as you said is not really the main
fighting gun violence anyway alright
well I think on this issue I think it's
a fascinating discussion obviously we're
not going to agree but hopefully the
audience will be able to get some
interesting stuff from this from this
discussion we've been speaking with Ben
Shapiro Breitbart news editor at large
the book is bullies how the left's
culture of fear and intimidation
silences America been really great to
have you on would love to have you back
again
it's blast